the value of the limit as x approaches 0
of 1 over x to the third times the
definite integral from 0 to x of t
natural log of 1 plus t
all of that over t to the fourth plus 4
dt is
now when you see an integral like this
your first temptation is to try to solve
the integral try to find the
anti-derivative of this expression here
and you might try to experiment maybe
with
inverse trig functions maybe arc tangent
looks tempting over here but you have
this natural log maybe you could do it
with integration by parts but very
quickly or maybe not so very quickly
you'll realize that this is a nearly
impossible integral to solve or to
simply solve using analytical methods
but lucky for us this problem isn't just
about solving this integral it's
actually about evaluating this limit and
if we rearrange this expression a little
bit it might become a little obvious to
you how we can approach this problem so
this is the limit
this is the limit as x
approaches 0
of let me write this in the numerator
because this could be dividing
multiplying by 1 over x to the third is
the same thing as dividing by x to the
third so this is the integral from 0 to
x of t
natural log of 1 plus t
all of that over t to the fourth plus 4
dt
and all of that over
all of that over x to the third and now
this is probably ringing bells in some
of your brains
and what we see here is okay we don't
know how to evaluate this integral over
here but what what what does this
integral approach as x approaches zero
what is the limit of this numerator
expression as it approaches zero well
you're going to get so let me just write
it the limit the limit as as it
approaches zero so the limit
as x approaches zero
of
0 to x
all of that stuff in the side dt is
going to equal
the integral from 0 it's going to
approach the integral from 0 to 0 of all
of that stuff
dt and an integral from a definite
integral from zero to zero we're not
moving at all along the horizontal or
the t axis and so this is just going to
be
zero and if we do the same thing in the
denominator that's much simpler if we do
the same thing in the denominator the
limit
as x approaches 0
of x to the third that's clearly also
going to be 0. so we took the limits of
the numerator and denominator we got 0
over 0 that's the indeterminate form and
so now the bell should be working
should be
ringing very loudly in your brain and
screaming l'hopital's rule
la patal's rule
la patal's rule and i've done several
videos on this in the calculus playlist
but this just tells us if we evaluate
the limit of the numerator as it
approaches zero and the limit of the
denominators approach zero and we get an
indeterminate form then this limit is
going to be the exact same thing
assuming the limit exists of the limit
as x approaches 0 of the derivative of
this expression over the derivative of
this expression now let's do the
denominator first since that's easier
what's the derivative of x to the third
well that's just 3
x squared and what's the derivative of
the denom of the numerator and just as a
reminder and i'm just going to break out
the fundamental theorem of calculus the
derivative with respect to x from some
constant to x of
f of t dt
is just equal to
is just equal to f of x you're kind of
undoing you're undoing the integration
here you just get f of x just the
function with respect to x so the
derivative of this with respect to x is
just going to be
this function with respect to x instead
of t so it's going to be x
natural log that was an ugly natural log
natural log
of 1 plus x
all of that over
x to the fourth plus four
now when we try to evaluate the limit
here what happens if we do the numerator
if we do the same thing we did up here
this numerator still evaluates to zero
you get zero times natural log of one
that's zero as well so that's all zero
the denominator still evaluates to zero
so we have indeterminate form again so
we might be tempted to just go straight
do lopital's rule again take the
derivative of the numerator and then
take the derivative of the denominator
and that would work but you can or maybe
you'll see that this is a pretty hairy
thing to take a derivative of and maybe
we might have to take a derivative again
after that so this could get very very
very hairy so instead of just straight
up just taking a derivative of the
numerator and derivative of the
denominator again let's see if we can
simplify this a little bit and we can so
this is the same thing this is equal to
the limit
as x approaches 0. i'm just going to put
the x to the fourth plus 4 in the
denominator so it's x
natural log of 1 plus x all of that over
this 3x squared
all of that over 3x squared and i'm just
if i'm dividing by something and
dividing by something else that's just
like dividing by that first thing so
this is x to the fourth
plus 4. i just put this in the
denominator and we can simplify this we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by x
and now let's try to evaluate this limit
as x approaches zero in the numerator we
get natural log of one so that's zero so
this is approaching zero over and if we
do in the denominator we have 3 times 0
times 4 so that's going to be 0 once
again indeterminate form so now let's
apply l'hopital's rule again but we can
apply it on a simpler expression on
natural a natural log of 1 plus x over
three x times x to the fourth plus four
so let's do that so this is going to be
equal to assuming the limit exists
this is equal to the limit
as x approaches zero of the derivative
of the numerator the derivative of
natural log of 1 plus x that's just 1
over 1 plus x
over the derivative of the denominator
we just have to do a little product rule
here derivative of the first function is
derivative of 3x is just 3
times the section second function which
is x to the fourth
plus four
plus
the first function 3x is just the
product rule times the derivative of the
second function the derivative of this
is 4x to the third
x to the third
now when we approach
zero what happens to this value what
what what is the numerator and the
denominator approach the numerator
approaches one over one plus zero or
just one
the denominator approaches three
times zero plus four three times four
plus this is just going to be zero plus
zero so this is equal to
one
twelfth and we're done
this crazy looking limit with this
integrate with this integral that we
couldn't solve is just equal to
12. so so thank goodness we had
lopital's rule so we didn't have to
actually solve this take the
anti-derivative anti-derivative of this
expression